hyundai squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur vous le savez déjà parce
qu'en fait c'est marqué dans le titre
bon forêts voilà je la construis le
petit chef chuck ne permet de
sauvegarder voilà mêmes sans faire
exprès au [ __ ] du coup il fait nuit et
ya le petit feu juste là qui va nous
permettre de nourrir par exemple de ce
lapin voilà qui regardaient ça
attentivement bien là ya pas mal de
nouveautés dans cette mise à jour pour
votre plus grand plaisir déjà hoyos à
ses nouveaux seins gaz bomb a écouté on
va faire ça tout de suite oui ça a de la
gueule
on va mettre ça là attendez up nickel il
faut 21 bois et 60 brindille brassens et
surtout des brady en fait mais regardez
le truc quoi je suis carrément pas
protégé c'est une petite brady qui me
protège alors là je suis en train de
coupes en herbe qui est en train de
copuler avec une pierre donc j'ai aucune
idée de 6,7 terme va quand même tombé au
plus grand désespoir de cette fière oui
je suis désolé pierre oui j'ai volé ton
âme et je sens qu'on va mettre une
plongée a construit ce truc
d'accord ça veux m'attaquer voilà j'ai
juste manger un petit coup au pas
pendant que je mange jeune femme aux
tétons qui pointent à l'est et donne une
ba ça tombe bien le sujet vous montrer
autre chose en rapport avec justement
j'avais besoin de caen a même mis en feu
mais revient enfin le court avec mais
non mais non mais on était là en train
de construire notre cabane ça faisait
longtemps que c'est peut-être ce n'était
pas arrivé à une agression comme ça dès
le début à la regarder à côté de quoi on
a parlé au lac et al
oh non je voulais copuler avec toi le
faire comme le caillou avec son âme
arbre alors c'est reparti on va se
mettre hors un nouvel animal regardez
c'est génial ils ont rajouté sarsgaard
et bambi mon ami qui me fuit pas ton ami
que ça finalement
trêve de plaisanterie il est temps de
passer à la construction déjà va faire
un feu voilà parce que moi je veux qu'on
reste en vie oh ça c'est fait on
l'allument
et on ne fait rien parce qu'on n'a pas
de boucle sur doumbia un piège à lapins
on va se faire un [ __ ] de caen mon
gars en pl je suis sûr qu'un nain qui
tombera dans les leurs de construire le
gars des mots attention non mais non
mais je coupe des brindilles et tu t'es
mis là en travers et je peux même pas de
cuir on va cacher l'épreuve vient hop
voilà cette pelote a poussé dans le vent
de cet animal mort je vous le promets ça
commence à ressembler à quelque chose en
fait vers une petite terrasse voilà
après il est vrai qu'en cas de bataille
contre les indigènes il enjambe [ __ ]
c'est terminé mais bon
c'est ça c'est regardez comme c'est beau
avec le petit soleil au dessus on dirait
la petite cabane s'emmure dans la
prairie
ah bah oui mais ça c'est les accidents
qui arrivent tout le temps se sent-il et
le piège à lapins et fonctionnel on peut
faire une table sans malice tech la nuit
tombe messieurs dames
regardez ce beau coucher de soleil et
ses éclats de bois qui me font plein
cicatrices au visage déjà je suis
scandalisé devant mon pied j'ai la pac i
know who mais que dis-je
mais vivant mais que dis je connais ni
un lapin vivant oh oui je me réactiver
assez fantastique
c'est fantastique pas content tu t'es
échapper non non pas jusqu'au bout
tu ne peux pas m appelles tu es le
pourra pas viens là non aux îles a fait
la technique de haut je t'ai retrouver
vient là avoue toi vaincu un nom mais
que vois-je un lapin qui s'est fait
attraper les hommes je mets là dedans
voilà le piège est là où ne sait jamais
mais que vois-je un lapin qui s'est fait
prendre
mais viala ce lapin bloque la cage
attendait parce que ben tu fais quoi
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font tous ces
animaux à m'envahir j'en peux plus j'ai
faim fauchon à manger laissez vous faire
pour une fois dans votre vie non of the
same avec un arbre ça peut marcher c'est
l'heure du combat
vas-y viens viens là vient là dedans via
un kit en empêche abba va regarder il se
fait entre eux à aa2 v1 c'est injuste oh
oui tiens je t'avais dit que c'était
injuste c'est bien fait pour ta qu au
poiré et toi je te tue à la main mais
qu'est ce qui t'arrive ou coutu cousue
au bot pabian ou data smiley a tenté de
cacher il savait qu'il allait être pendu
comme ça et qu'on espère voir ses fesses
sans que personne ne nous en empêche le
psychopathe aura fait il aide son
prochain
mais c'est extrêmement millions mais ça
va pas se passer comme ça vous avez
voulu m'attaquer
vous assumez non il ya un mec en
position foetale juste devant nous quoi
il fait peur lui c'est un vote je pense
à oui dites moi que c'est un bug au non
non non non non non non non mais on
était méchant déjà d'un combat vous
n'allez pas tous vouloir me combattants
de contrat en plus de ça ah ah ah [ __ ]
on s'est fait chier deux fois construire
est un truc pour mourir l'âge construit
plus rien à part des pièges et des trucs
qui vous feront tout ce beau monde à de
feu au piège à lapin au but she's ça
cuit va se faire une petite cabine voilà
des wc si jamais c'est toujours très
utiles khwaja turquin n'a pas là dedans
tu as vu sa cote est devenu maître -
magot regardez on a capturé un gros
lapin
mme ocana petite cabane voilà elle est
belle elle est mignonne voilà elle est
petite mais bon on s'en fout non on vit
bien là dans ok nous il nous faudra des
choses et même une petite fenêtre et ou
alors personnes se moquent maintenant
que ça c'est fait et ce que j'ai capturé
un lapin toujours pas mais [ __ ] on
sait qu'on allait s'arrêter là ah mais
non on va faire trois pièges à l'aso
boom est dehors
um et de deux pièges il y en a un de
chaque côté on va faire un pile en face
est beau mon gars on a plein de pièges
est-ce qu'on a capturé un lapin en prime
bien sûr que non ça marche jamais il est
l'heure de se coucher et de faire un
massacre au réveil
alors ils sont où mais regardez
maintenant avec des morceaux de
vêtements on peut améliorer nos armes
mais bon on attend sagement en ligne aux
eaux
plus jamais ça à la ba aa je veux
assister au massacre
yabiladi datum donnait mois venez faire
venez avec moi venez moi ça se dit pas
albanais excusez moi je vais au chaud
pendant que je vous vois tous mourir et
aucun problème il ya aucun surtout ne
pas paniquer qui ouvre le mal à ba3
pourquoi c'est ballot regardez le lao
qui monte aux arbres g capture à la pas
[ __ ] au fort s'est passé tellement
mais je vais capturés c'est un patou
apparemment un mot je t'ai entendu mon
gars et oui toi t'es pas un ninja les
morts suivant aléas de pièges
allez allez allez aux habitants c'est le
piège à la fois qui marche le mieux
qu'on ne l'a pas il attend qu'ils aient
un max d'ennemis avant de dire aussi
laurent dever capturés mais il tue son
pote
alors il essaie de couper la corde mais
qu'est ce qui se passe ici tout comprend
rien et jamais atteinte attend que ça
passe comme ça déjà
mais tout le monde se met sur la gueule
mais qu'est ce c'est que ce bordel
regardez une défense je t'aime je te
donnerai du lapin mon grand mais alain
mais il est cannibale en fait faut pas
déranger audap même et c'est ça un
va-t-en laisse le manger biatch cru
gardez le et avait sept top
tranquillement bon cette bataille part
légèrement steak je tiens à le dire
le mec est pendu n'est plus pendu il se
balade basse et rondard maintenant dont
il met
voilà je veux la tête la tête qui est à
la tête qui va rebondir combat propre
tête
non mais faut il faut juste faire un
mètre sur ta gauche ou sur la droite
pour pouvoir et qu'elle savait que cette
corde
non mais c'est prison ils ont saccagé
mon corps au [ __ ] mais bordel de merde
regardez-moi ça la porte est fermée
c'est comme quand vos toilettes pis y'a
quelqu'un la porte est fermée et ben là
c'est pas ton chez toi c'est bien donc
la porte est fermée
oui oh ah ouais l'efficacité de ce piège
est vraiment incroyable c'est aussi
efficace que moi qui chante pas séduire
une fille cette tête que j'ai ramassé je
peux la faire cuire voilà l nouveauté
ils se sont montrés depuis une heure et
demie jl pu trouver des pièces sur la
plage et que j'avais fait une bombe
j'aurais pu faire un crâne bon ben c'est
pas une blague malheureusement c'est un
rôle à part toi la queue entre les
jambes
vous avez saccagé mon copain jamie au
moins trois minutes à faire
alors du coup sûr le feu logiquement il
ya un crâne et si je combine un crâne
avec un stick
ça donne un ch'ti crâne à les questions
à faire moi j'ai une massue crâne mon
gars pause face au serbe à l'aise ça
fait mal hein hein ça avec le crâne de
ton frère mon gars tient aux plages te
pique je te pique à l'option pic ou non
c'est enfin fini [ __ ] on mange des bus
pour fêter ça voilà un [ __ ] c'est en
p2 au bac que vois-je un homme qui
flotte dans l'air il devrait y bat il
devrait entrer juive c'est ce qu'il a
fait avant que je termine un phrase on a
repoussé l'offensive des indigènes et le
soleil se lève sur le campement
la nuit a été un peu mouvementée tout le
monde est décédée et compris cette femme
que je t-bag sans le moindre scrupule et
tu piques que picopix cette paire de
fesses qui te déplaît ça fait du bien et
mal agencé jaffa cette vidéo sur de
forest [ __ ] on a annoncé jamais autant
battu contre des indiens dans une vidéo
c'était la nuit la plus mouvementée de
toute notre vie nous on a remporté haut
la main un et le bas les fesses
attendez attendez attendez non mais les
délires sexuelle un peu chelou c'est
faut arrêter tout de suite quoi non mais
je veux pas prendre part à sa hockey
laissez moi finalement trop
tranquillement ça faisait longtemps
qu'on n'était pas feinte the forest mais
[ __ ] qu'est ce que c'était bon et
cette nuit là restera gravé dans nos
mémoires jamais j'espère si vous a plu
comme d'habitude et si c'est le cas vous
savez quoi faire on se retrouve très
vite dans une nouvelle vidéo tient tout
le monde
m